yell buzz feeding my name is Klaus
Martin and my personal transformation
happened in a nine by six prison cell I
[Music]
was raised in a heavily drug enforcer
community in the Lower East Side section
of Manhattan people would ask me what do
you want to be when you grow up
I'll tell them that I wanted to be rich
and the first opportunity I got was
through the world of drugs I started
smoking at the age of eleven and at the
age of thirteen I made my first sale
this led me to the corner on Broome and
Alger Street where I began to pitch
other drugs with the local guys who
respected my hustle and by the age of 19
I was a leader of a cocaine distributing
ring in New York City I was making over
two million dollars a year my first run
with NYPD was at the age of 13 and from
then I was in and out of jail for the
next few years when I was 23 I was
caught by federal agents and was
sentenced to seven years in prison
during my incarceration I was overweight
and extremely unhealthy the doctors in
president told me that I could die of a
heart attack within five years but with
a seven years sentence in front of me I
was determined I was not gonna die in
prison so I started working out I
developed a workout routine using just
my body weight that could be done in a
small prison cell and in just six months
I lost 70 pounds then I started training
other inmates and I helped over 20 and
made schools over a thousand pounds
combined as my release day got closer I
got into an altercation with an officer
and was placed in solitary confinement I
was beaten and thrown into a cell alone
with my thoughts I kept asking myself
why I wrote a ten page letter out to my
family explain what happened and that I
was in coming home anytime soon and then
I realized that I didn't have a stamp to
send it after two weeks in solitary my
sister sent me a letter and suggested I
read Psalm 91 from the Bible I flipped
open right to Psalm 91 and that's when a
stamp fell out it was just that that I
needed to send out my letter
I read the whole Bible from cover to
cover and received a sense of peace and
calm despite my surroundings my whole
perspective on life changed I began to
believe that my purpose was to give back
instead of destroying the people around
me when I got out I realized my way of
giving back was through the world of
fitness and that's when I started comedy
calm body is a present style boot camp
that hires formerly incarcerated
individuals to teach fitness classes
based on the workout I developed in
myself in just two and a half years calm
body has gone from workouts in the park
to studios in NYC with 12 employees over
7,000 clients and over 200 classes per
week my business has been featured in
over a hundred international media
outlets today I travel the country
visiting presidents training inmates in
hopes of creating a pipeline of trainers
for calm body our mission is to create a
bridge between two communities young
professionals and formerly incarcerated
individuals at calm body we view each
other as real human beings and seek to
break down the stereotypes that formerly
incarcerated individuals face
whoever dwells in the shelter of the
most high will rest in the shadow
Almighty
thanks for reading close
you
[Music]
[Applause]